Redwoods grow in damp, foggy forests.
They collect a lot of their water
from fog, and, in the process,
they help keep the surrounding
environment wet.
If we were here in the morning, with a
lot of fog in the air, you'd be able to
see water droplet's beading on leaves and
then dripping down to the ground.
Anyway.
The reason I want to show you trees
is because they play a key role in
web development.
Besides being beautiful
awe inspiring giants,
web developers use them to represent
the data that makes up websites.
Here, let me show you what I mean.
This is a family tree.
You've probably seen
something like this before.
There's a parent.
And two children.
And yeah.
I know it takes two parents to make
a kid but, just ignore that for now.
Pretend it only takes one parent.
For this family, you would say that
Diego and Jamal are children of Zhalisa,
and you would say that Zhalisa is
the parent to Jamal and Diego.
You could also say that Diego and
Jamal are siblings.
We use the same kind of family
terms like child, siblings and
parent to describe relationships
like these inside a data tree.
Now a tree is just a type of
data in computer science.
They're used to represent
hierarchical data.
That is to say, bits of information
that belong to each other.
In this case, element 3 and
element 2 both belong to element 1.
And just like a family,
the children can be parents too and
that's it, that's a tree.
I brought this tree up because your HTML
turns into a tree a lot like this one.
Elements will belong to each other or
be descended from one another.
There are children and parents and
children have children.
Now I know that can sound
a little confusing so
here, let me show you what I mean.